[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité il est le chef
d'état d'un pays en guerre depuis 7 mois
voleodymeersky le président
ukrainien était mon invité exceptionnel
pour face au territoire ce vendredi une
émission enregistrée depuis Kef et
diffusé notamment sur TV5 Monde et sur
elle c'est P vous découvrirez un extrait
dans quelques instants dans ce journal à
peine mise à la réelle reprend déjà du
service la centrale à charbon Émile
Huchet sera de nouveau opérationnel
d'ici quelques jours conséquences de la
crise énergétique nous expliquera
Moselle télévision
symbole du lien social et des
territoires les radios associatifs
peinent à susciter de nouvelles
vocations les jeunes déserte les ont
dans cette rentrée nous dira LMTV ça
dans un instant pour faire des selfies
et autres vidéos choisissez votre box en
Bretagne la première selfie box vient
d'ouvrir ses portes pour une quinzaine
d'euros il vous est désormais possible
de poser et de poster dans des décors
originaux un sujet sans filtre de thé
vert en fin de journal
je vous le disais dans les titres c'est
une interview exceptionnelle réalisée
depuis Kef et diffuser notamment sur TV5
Monde et LCP volodime zenenski le
président
ukrainien était mon invité dans
l'émission Face au territoire ce
vendredi à la tête d'un pays en guerre
depuis 7 mois l'ancien acteur devenu
président a notamment évoqué le rôle
joué par la France pour soutenir son
pays et sa relation particulière avec
Emmanuel Macron regardez cet extrait
je voudrais que la France fasse des
puces
et ce n'est pas une question à propos de
France c'est la concerne tout autre pays
nous avons besoin de plus d'armements
ce sera assez je pense que vous me
comprenez
le président Baden m'a dit que tu
demandes beaucoup mais je te comprends
c'est ce que moi je ferai aussi ta place
donc
je demande beaucoup mais je te comprends
il nous aide
[Musique]
plus encore plus d'armement
exclusive de volody meilleure zenenski
depuis quai rendez-vous sur les sites
internet de TV5 Monde et LCP mais aussi
sur les sites des partenaires de
l'émission Face au territoire Nice-Matin
Ouest-France France Antilles la montagne
et 20 minutes je vous le disais dans les
titres sept mois après le début du
conflit en Ukraine la crise énergétique
guette l'Europe alors que l'hiver
approche pour éviter les coupures de
courant toutes les solutions sont
étudiées même les plus polluantes parmi
elles la remise en fonctionnement de
centrales à charbon exemple en Moselle
avec un site qui venait d'être arrêté il
y a quelques mois seulement et qui
reprendra du service dans quelque jours
un reportage de Moselle télévision sur
place
face à la crainte d'un blackout le
combustible le plus nocif pour le climat
arrive par camion à Saint-Avold il
faudra 600000 tonnes de charbon pour
relancer Émilie chez cet hiver condamné
par la loi énergie climat la centrale
thermique avait coupé le courant le 31
mars ça fait de l'activité mais moi ça
veut dire qu'on a louper quelque chose
parce que la pollution est quand même là
les 200000 tonnes que vous voyez là CO2
qui va être produit
il est là on le sait on sait que c'est
pas bien et on est obligé de reprendre
donc il y a quelque chose qui était
loupé quelque part laissez sur le
carreau il y a 5 mois 68 salariés ont
accepté de retourner au charbon un
devoir pour cet ancien technicien
d'exploitation canton de revenir la
centrale était toujours là aussi bien en
été qu'en hiver quand il y avait une
demande de RTE les salariés de la
centrale eux ont toujours produit
et que là ils reviennent et puis ils
savent que
les Français quand eux pour que pour
qu'ils électricité cet hiver avec un
redémarrage prévu le premier octobre la
tranche 6 reprend vite mais avant de
tourner à pleine puissance soit 600
mégawh elle nécessite d'urgence une
opération de maintenance chiffrée à 10
millions d'euros pour gaz à l'énergie
Émilie Luché carbura pendant 2500 heures
d'octobre à fin mars pour compenser ses
émissions carbone gaz à l'énergie devra
verser 40 euros par tonnes de CO2 dégagé
un fond d'investissement local soit près
de 50 millions d'euros pour cette ultime
retour de flammes la logique pour nous
c'était de ne pas forcément acheter des
crédit carbone sur le marché
international où on allait demander à
notre trader d'acheter des crédits
carbone en Chine avec relativement peu
de sens mais de réussir à garder cet
argent en proximité et en région et donc
on a passé un partenariat avec le
Conseil régional Grand Est ce qui
travaille forcément avec nous avec le
ministère pour réussir à développer des
projets de compensation dans la région
en ces temps de sobriété énergétique
l'or noir qui a fait l'âge d'or de la
mosal-est pourraient ainsi une dernière
fois accompagner sa réindustrialisation
lors de la fermeture de la centrale gaz
à l'énergie s'était engagé à horizon
2026 à recréé plus d'emplois que ceux
détruit le groupe Conti parvenir grâce
aux énergies renouvelables comme la
biomasse ou l'hydrogène
voilà il vous le savez les collectivités
tentent aussi de surmonter la hausse des
coûts de l'énergie partout en France de
nombreuses piscines sont fermées pour
réaliser des économies d'autres arrivent
à rester ouvertes grâce aux travaux de
rénovation réalisés en amont avant la
crise c'est le cas par exemple d'une
piscine intercommunale dans la Loire un
sujet de Céline Ersilia pour TL7 la
chaîne de la Loire
c'est le moment du grand nettoyage pour
le centre aquatique de génilac la
piscine intercommunale est financée par
18 communes des élus qui ont voulu
devancer la crise énergétique en 2019 un
premier investissement a permis
d'installer un système de traitement des
eaux rejetés et cette année c'est tout
le système d'éclairage qui a été
remplacé par des lampes à LED un
investissement indispensable face à
l'augmentation de 20% du prix de
l'électricité sans faire de grandes
économies cela a permis de bien amortir
le choc malgré une augmentation par
exemple à titre d'exemple de 20% des
prix de l'électricité
nos investissements jusqu'à ce jour nous
ont permis d'économiser
99 euros alors alors que nous avons
réduit de 16% de consommation électrique
l'équipement récupère également l'eau de
pluie versée dans ce bassin de rétention
à proximité de la piscine un bassin qui
a permis cet été d'arroser les jardins
gérés par l'association des Restos du
cœur de Rive-de-Gier
une idée qui pourrait aller plus loin
avec un nouveau projet celui d'optimiser
l'eau des bassins récupéré toute l'année
dans le futur nous verrons ça avec les
communes associées pourquoi ne pas leur
mettre cette eau à disposition mais là
ou encore une fois c'est un
investissement il faut il faudrait qu'il
faudra gérer qu'il faudra et puis voir
la répartition entre les communes le
projet devrait mettre encore quelques
temps à se concrétiser mais il
permettrait de mettre à disposition
entre 6 et 7000 m3 d'eau par an des
solutions pour préserver l'eau mais
aussi pour favoriser l'usage des
transports en savoir un nouveau centre
de maintenance vient d'être inauguré
dans une gare historique de la SNCF
celui-ci permettra d'entretenir et de
réparer une cinquantaine de locomotives
par semaine des détails d'Emmanuel
jaunes de la rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc
sur place
la vieille retombe de maintenance pour
locomotive de fret de la gare de Modane
ne pouvait espérer meilleur avenir
comptant parmi les rares bâtiments des
alentours à avoir survécu à la Seconde
Guerre mondiale le site a retrouvé des
couleurs remplaçant depuis peu le pôle
de Saint-Jean-de-Maurienne qui a dû
laisser sa place au futur tracé du lieu
Turin en fait on a libéré des terrains à
Saint-Jean
reconstruit la capacité de maintenance
ici à Modane donc ça fait partie aussi
du grand projet c'est un vrai bel outil
industriel de maintenance qui va nous
permettre de travailler en qualité il y
a beaucoup de locomotives ici puisque
c'est l'une à forte pas à donc il faut
pousser en même temps qu'on tire les
trains donc il faut beaucoup de
locomotives fiables et disponible et ce
nouvel outil très moderne de maintenance
va nous permettre d'être efficace dans
les trafics de la vallée et
France-Italie composée d'une équipe de 6
personnes ce Paloma contraction de petit
ateliers local de maintenance s'occupe
de plus d'une cinquantaine de
locomotives chaque semaine un labeur qui
va donc beaucoup se faciliter grâce à
cette réhabilitation donc on est passé
on va dire de la préhistoire au 21e
siècle avec des installations dignes de
travail correctement dans des bonnes
conditions du chauffage et des
outillages d'un écrit à disposition une
vraie métamorphose par rapport aux
locaux historique et qui est nécessité
un budget de 8 millions d'euros
subventionnés à 95% par les fonds de
telte le tunnel oralpin lui en Turin
c'est très très symbolique on a voulu
réinstaller un centre amodan Fournaux
dans un bâtiment historique La Rotonde
de Modane qui a plus de 100 ans et
effectivement c'est vraiment un symbole
de se dire que le frais de ferroviaire
reste en Maurienne reste à Modane
fourneau et continue l'aventure qui a
débuté il y a plus de il y a plus de 100
ans maintenant parce qu'on avait un
risque potentiel que ce centre part de
la de la Savoie de la Maurienne
d'ailleurs ce local de maintenance fret
devrait gagner en volume dans les
prochaines années prévoyant déjà de
nouvelles embauches en vue de
l'ouverture du fameux ouvrage Lyon-Turin
prévu pour la fin de la
leur mission est de donner ou de
redonner le sourire à des enfants
malades Iron Man Batman ou encore
Captain America les super héros Marvel
ce sont donnés rendez-vous à Bordeaux le
temps d'un après-midi derrière les
déguisements des policiers qui jouent
leur rôle héroïque pour la bonne cause
un reportage vivant branché pour TV7 la
chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
[Musique]
c'est qui ton super héros préféré
c'est génial ça fait rêver les enfants
enfin c'est une super journée et en plus
pour une super occasion enfin une bonne
raison avec admiration
kadmiration et ils aimeraient être à
leur place
structure gonflable atelier créatif ou
encore réalité virtuelle sont au
programme de cette journée la première
journée d'inclusion sociale entre
enfants valides et malades rendus
possible grâce à une agence de sécurité
privée ça le peu que nous toucher
puisqu'il se déplace dans toute les
villes de France donc on a décidé aussi
de contribuer à ça dans les hôpitaux
tout et à les aider financièrement voire
même logistiquement à cette occasion la
société a offert un chèque de 400 euros
au super-héros pour mieux préparer les
nouvelles missions qui les attendent à
travers les hôpitaux de la région
elles ont connu leur heure de gloire au
début des années 80 les radios
associatives continuent 40 ans plus tard
de créer le lien social au cœur des
territoires cependant cette année nombre
d'entre elles Penta recruter des
volontaires en service civique les 18-25
ans sont notamment invités à rejoindre
ces médias locaux pour des missions
d'animation ou de communication alors ce
service civique s'essouffle-t-il élément
de réponse avec Anthony Python pour elle
aime ça
c'est le cas chaque année radio Alpa
ouvre son antenne à de nouveaux concepts
d'émissions mais là le directeur des
programmes les attend toujours une
dizaine de cases sont disponibles cette
saison pour ceux qui souhaitent prendre
leur envol sur les ondes tous les sujets
sont possibles savoir qu'on peut faire
de la radio et une fois qu'on a goûté la
radio moi je le sais on prend le virus
et celui-là il est pas mortel puisque on
poursuit tout simplement une aventure
radiophonique
on s'est rentré il manque une quinzaine
de bénévoles pour faire vivre l'antenne
de Radio Alpa la radio associative a
fêté ses 40 ans cette année et depuis
toujours le cœur de son projet c'est de
former ceux qui s'intéressent au métier
de la radio quand on vient déposer un
projet d'émission à Radio Alpa vous
n'êtes pas tout seul on est là pour vous
accompagner pour vous aider à savoir
faire et après notre but à nous une fois
qu'on a fait cette étape là de formation
et bien vous êtes à l'antenne et vous
êtes libre parce que le projet de la
radio est un projet d'éducation
populaire qui est l'émancipation et donc
la liberté pour prendre contact avec
Radio Alpa direction la MJC Prévert dans
la vieille ville du Mans certains
anciens bénévoles de radio alpas sont
devenus aujourd'hui de vrais
professionnels de la radio tout le monde
c'est une activité que les moins de 20
ans ne peuvent ignorer les selfies
soient la prise d'une photo portrait et
devenu un véritable phénomène de société
depuis une quinzaine d'années la
tendance c'est même accentuée avec les
vidéos postées sur les réseaux sociaux
et c'est pour répondre à ce besoin
d'images permanent que des selfie room
ont vu le jour un peu partout dans le
monde l'un de ces espaces vient d'ouvrir
en Bretagne plusieurs décors permettent
ainsi de prendre des photos et des
vidéos originales selon les envies et
les humeurs commentaires de Capucine
Colin guillauchin pour TVA à Rennes
la première salle qu'on peut voir ici
c'est l'esprit kawaii donc ça veut dire
mignon en japonais clip vidéo shooting
photo post Instagram sans en garde
Vern-sur-Seiche et probablement
l'endroit rêvé des influenceurs Anaïs
Soula 26 ans vient d'ouvrir la première
selfie room de France le principe est
simple d'ibox 10 ambiances pour créer du
contenu aposté sur ses réseaux sociaux
le monde évolue beaucoup il y a 10-15
ans on n'aurait pas pu voir tout ça mais
du coup on a des nouveaux métiers donc
forcément des nouvelles demandes donc du
coup Storytime est fait pour cette
nouvelle demande chaque mois
l'entrepreneuse crée une nouvelle pièce
en fonction de la demande il lui faut
une à deux semaines pour construire le
décor et pour l'inspiration tout vient
des tendances actuelles
du moment aussi la saison si on arrive à
Noël on va faire plutôt un box Noël si
on arrive à Halloween on va faire
Halloween rassurez-vous pas besoin de
milliers de followers pour se rendre à
story time le hangar est accessible à
tous et ce jour-là justement c'est une
boutique brestoise qui a privatisé le
lieu objectif prendre les photos qui
seront postées sur Instagram à la
rentrée on va gagner beaucoup de temps
puisque là en fait en une journée on va
faire 12 publications à peu près sur
Instagram donc sachant qu'en moyenne sur
une journée on en fait plutôt deux trois
maximum mais là on a aucun aller on n'a
pas les aléas de la météo on est dans un
box on est isolé on peut s'étaler on va
beaucoup beaucoup plus vite en fait ça
qui est bien pour avoir accès à toutes
les box pendant une heure et demie
comptez entre 15 et 18 euros Anaïs sous
la compte bien développé son entreprise
déjà elle envisage de créer un second
espace avec une dizaine d'ambiance
supplémentaires
voilà si ce prendre en photo ou en vidéo
peut-être utile et plaisant faire du
sport à tout âge c'est encore mieux à
Limoges la pratique des arts martiaux
est accessible à tous les publics des
trois ans grâce à un club local la
Martia académie les plus petits peuvent
ainsi découvrir le taekwondo tout en
s'amusant et en se dépensant des
sessions sont également accessibles pour
les personnes en situation de handicap à
ce sujet de Benjamin Delmas pour cet
animal sur place
enlève le genou droit devant nous en
pivote ici
[Musique]
et là on détend la jante devant soi
ces mouvements sont ceux du Taekwondo
seule condition pour s'initier à cette
art martial avoir au moins trois ans le
club martial Academy organise une
journée portes ouvertes pour le plus
petit l'objectif à prendre les bases de
ce sport de pieds
d'abord les arts martiaux et le rendre
très ludique donc ça passe aussi par des
ateliers de jeux comme vous avez pu le
voir donc l'idée c'est vraiment aussi de
montrer que les arts martiaux certes il
y a du sérieux il y a de la discipline
mais il y a aussi du jeu et du plaisir à
volonté un sport pour tous ce jour-là
deux personnes en situation de handicap
participer au cours le taekwondo se met
en apprentissage à se défendre quel que
soit sa situation
sport d'apprentissage et de
de respect que je vous le disais tout à
l'heure et ça JK me la prime
[Musique]
donc deux têtes au-dessus d'elle très
bien on applaudi pour elle
partager des expériences et faire
grandir c'est tout l'objectif de la
martial Academy les élèves les plus
expérimentés participent à cette
dynamique en contribuant la formation
des plus jeunes
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça leur transmet à ces
petits tout d'abord ça leur permet
d'être respectueux d'avoir une certaine
discipline et forcément du plaisir parce
que le taekwondo c'est pas juste un art
martial on combat tout le temps etc
c'est surtout du plaisir
voilà tout à fait autre chose dans
l'actualité petit peu juteuses la
récolte des pommes à débuter en cette
mi-septembre dans les Vosges 25
bénévoles d'un pressoir associatif se
relais pour cueillir pour trier pour
presser le précieux fruit et le premier
bilan de la récolte se révèle mitigé
pour l'heure vous allez le voir
certaines pommes manquent d'eau après un
été chaud Hélène le plat héroli
Colombelles se sont glissées entre les
pommiers pour vos jeter les visions à
peine secouer les pommes chutes au sol
la récolte commence tout juste au verger
patrimonial de fraises près de Saint-Dié
et ce matin-là les membres de
l'association La Costelle passent sous
les 90 arbres vérifiez la maturité des
fruits le mieux c'est de couper la pomme
regardez les pépins s'ils sont bien
noirs les cavités aussi et puis la goûté
et aujourd'hui on a une solution iodée
qui nous permet de tester la maturité du
fruit c'est une solution qui qui met en
évidence de l'amidon ou pas d'amidon
dans le fruit donc s'il y a de l'amidon
elle est elle est verte encore
et plus ça va vers le vers le sucre vers
le glucose à ce moment là on peut
l'accueillir les fruits cueillis à la
main pas trop mûr se
conserva les
autres actions donc le pressoir ou les
25 bénévoles de l'association se
relèvent
mais c'est pour la convivialité on va
voir retour c'est une bande de copains
qui est là depuis plusieurs années et
puis voilà on est ensemble on va sur un
bon moment bon il y a des moments
transpirapés aussi mais bon dans
l'ensemble ça se passe bien si les
machines vont bien on va bien les gens
qui viennent ici ils viennent avec leurs
pommes et ils repartent avec leur jus
ils suivent tout le processus il y a pas
il y a rien entre les deux il y a rien
il y a pas d'ajout il y a rien les beaux
pommes votre jus vous arrivez à 9h si
vous avez 5 kg de pommes à 9h30 vous
repartez la récolte a été érogène
certains arbres ont vu leur fouille
tomber bien avant l'heure d'autres sont
chargés mais avec de petits calibres
seuls les pommiers situés près de points
d'eau s'en sortent bien le manque de
pluie interfère sur la qualité
donc ça bourre donc on est en train de
faire descendre la pulpe dans le
pressoir quoi tout simplement
d'habitude elles sont moins sèches
qu'est-ce qui se passe il a pas eu assez
d'eau donc du coup ça ça coince en
perspective une année moyenne en termes
de quantité mais des boissons sucrées
l'atelier du jus de pomme de fraises
sera ouvert aux particuliers 500 km
maximum jusqu'à la fin du mois d'octobre
direction la Martinique dans ce journal
ou comme en métropole l'érosion des
plages est devenue une problématique
très préoccupante depuis quelques années
pour lutter contre ce danger une
association martiniquaise développe une
technique innovante l'utilisation des
Sargasses cet algue souvent combattue
pour ses odeurs et nuisances se révèlent
en réalité très utile pour protéger les
plages de l'île les premiers résultats
constatés sont encourageants explication
et reportages de Maxime Le que pour via
ATV sur place regardez
ces derniers temps la pointe Fola a des
airs de laboratoire à ciel ouvert les 15
bénévoles de cette association ramassent
et rassemblent les Sargasses après
différentes phases de séchage d'une
durée de trois mois elles sont ensuite
entreposées sur les parcelles
fragilisées par l'érosion où elles ont
un lentement leur transformation en
sable c'est pas comme ça
donc ça force on a commencé à mettre des
sargas par dessus ensuite le sable on a
récupéré là-bas et aujourd'hui regardez
ce que ça a donné grâce à cette méthode
la plage a pu être consolidée sur 15
mètres et réhaussée d'environ 1 m
Stéphane ancien marin pêcheur en avait
assez de voir les Sargasses détruire son
lieu de travail alors depuis quatre ans
il essaye de les comprendre au lieu de
les combattre ça dit pourquoi pas ne pas
mettre la saga
successives et au fur et à mesure le de
l'évacuer de l'utiliser dans son domaine
le domaine de la saga normalement c'est
les 50 pages géométriques donc on a
utilisé les 50 pas cette initiative est
évidemment bénéfique pour la plage mais
également tout son écosystème les arbres
vous voyez là il y avait plus les
racines étaient à nu on a fait du comble
avec cette sargasme avec du sable qui a
permis aux arbres de se régénérer et de
s'équilibrer c'est donc tout le rivage
qui profite de cette métamorphose mais
aussi les habitués déjà bien renseignés
tout ça c'est tout ça c'est avec du
sable tout la moitié de la plage tout ça
à l'entrée de la plage il y avait
beaucoup d'érosion et ça m'a toujours
fait beaucoup de peine et si aujourd'hui
on a cette solution avec les Sargasses
je trouve ça génial de son côté Stéphane
espère qu'un jour se procédé sera
reconnu et reproduit sur d'autres sites
envahis nous sommes quand même du pays
on est quand même impactés directement
ça fait quatre années dedans j'espère
que une petite considération un
accompagnement une mise en avant ce
serait bien aussi afin notamment
d'anticiper la montée des olliers au
réchauffement climatique Stéphane rêve
d'installer une base expérimentale au
Vauclin à la pointe foulard
restons sur la plage mais revenons en
métropole dans l'Hérault précisément une
quarantaine d’œufs de tortues viennent
d'éclore et ont déjà rejoint la mer un
saut dans l'océan qui devrait être suivi
de beaucoup d'autres pour assurer la
protection des nids les bénévoles se
relaient une nuit et jour sur les plages
de la région image et explications
les bébés tortues sont sortis de leurs
œufs sur la plage de Valras-Plage une
quarantaine a éclos ce mercredi à 20h20
sont partis au large c'est très
important parce que ça leur permet de
prendre note en fait des signes de la
plage et peut-être dans le futur quand
elle sera mature de revenir pondre dans
ses plages et aux alentours les
associations estiment que tous les œufs
n'ont pas encore éclos en moyenne une
tortue en pond une centaine alors la
surveillance se poursuit pour éviter
toute perturbation durant l'incubation
24 heures sur 24 depuis le 17 juillet
nous avons moins de bénévoles qui sont
présents soit pour surveiller donc et le
nid tortue et aussi pour sensibiliser et
informer des usagers de la plage il faut
dire que cet événement est assez rare
sur notre
littor pire de nombreux curieux alors
les associations en profitent pour faire
de la sensibilisation
sont en danger une tortue qui va se
prendre dans un filet ne pourra plus
remonter donc va se noyer elle va mourir
donc là c'était l'occasion d'en parler
de montrer quelque chose de merveilleux
mais de dire attention on a tous une
part de responsabilité
dans la protection des tortues
voilà on referme ce journal avec ces
très belles images fournies par nos
partenaires corses de via télé paisés
sur l'île d'Elbe cette île italienne est
entrée bien sûr dans l'histoire pour
avoir été le terrain d'exil de Napoléon
1er en 1814 chaque année des visiteurs
français italiens ou du monde entier son
nombreux à visiter cette île située à 50
km de Bastia il se rendent notamment
dans la maison ou a vécu l'empereur
pendant 10 mois voilà c'est la fin de ce
grand JT des territoires merci de votre
fidélité on se retrouve très vite pour
une nouvelle édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]